have you put noodles before of course oh
great yeah but it's like for me I put my
little sauce in it go put your own
flavor in
it and this is Tesco's
flavor you I mean a little bit of sign
would have made it at least stand a
chance now talk us through this one well
this is this is Gary that's like um
casava in English and this is a Goosey I
don't know the English English for
I don't think there's an English
translation but yeah I've heard some
white people call it spinach for some
reason it does not look like the stuff
papey takes so I don't know where you
get spinach but yeah it could
[Music]
be oh we have the next one don't we I
think I know this one but who wins out
the two of
them